you're playing a game
you're on a boat that has to keep moving
when you come to a two-way Junction
stay left and you will fall off a cliff
face and die
stay right and you will come across some
very hungry bears
it's not looking that good
so what will it be
left or right
well it turns out both paths are gated
and the other closers once you make your
decision
but it takes a bit of time for the gate
to close
you have an idea
what if you go one way then immediately
turn around and choose the other sides
you can do this decision flipping faster
than the gates can close
I say by oscillating between you
effectively remain perpetuating in a
state of indecision
but what if we could apply to a similar
logic to prevent two parts of Aging
within a cell
would that even be possible
what would that tell us if it was
possible
well how convenient in this video we
will take a look at this recent paper
that used engineering principles to
rationally optimize aging Dynamics
towards extended longevity
and it's involved making a synthetic
Gene oscillator
so let's discuss
so the story starts with an observation
that was published in 2020
. in this paper the researchers
presented that yeast cells show two
different forms of Aging
either they slow down the biosynthesis
of heme which results in mitochondrial
dysfunction
or they lose the ability to cause
silencing or ribosomal DNA
for now you don't really need to
understand fully how these Pathways
operate within yeast
just appreciate that there are these two
mechanisms and two key protein players
involved in their regulation is Sir II
that controls gene silencing
and how before that controls the heme
production
so like how you could go left or right
in the game example at the start of this
video
and that either offense occurs and the
cell is committed to it
so like in the game the question is
raised
what controls which path has taken and
can you manipulate yeast such that they
prolong this decision and live longer
well that brings us to this latest paper
engineering longevity the sign of a
synthetic Gene oscillator to slow
cellular aging
where essentially they re-saw this
dichotomous endpoint in their data
where they see one fate chosen over the
other
and wondered if they could do something
about this to cause it to oscillate
between the two Fades instead of
committing to one
to understand this we first have to look
at the gene circuit thought to underpin
this decision-making and we can see it's
a toggle switch
increased activity of SAR 2 represses
hap so that hap can no longer repress
her too Society increases
conversely if we increase hap that
represses her2 and so the repression of
harp declines and therefore hap
increases so they're both
self-reinforcing pathways
now what's presented in this miscurrent
paper is what would happen if this Gene
circuit was changed from this toggle
switch
to an oscillator
and by having an oscillator it prevents
the cell committing to either of the
sulfates
in this case ribosome DNA silencing or
hemebiogenesis
both of which a sign of Aging in these
cells
now one example of an oscillator in
biological systems is a delayed negative
feedback loop
let's explain
this time let's imagine that star 2
still represses hap but hap is now a
strong activator of satu
therefore if we repress hap it prevents
more side two activity
if we lose Saturn activity that means
that hap is no longer repressed
if haps no longer repressed then it
becomes active and it can reactivate its
tattoo
and the story continues
it's an oscillation
now many oscillatory systems within
cells actually Decay over time
so it was important to actually check
that this you know theoretical idea
could actually work and could be built
into a biological system
which leads us to the question of well
how exactly do you go about
re-engineering a system like this
well we turn to genetic engineering to
turn up from an inhibitor to an
activator of setu they had to edit the
promoter region the region of DNA that
regulates the activity of satu
to include one that is bound and
activated by hap
I make it sound trivial but it requires
some tailoring and understanding of
genetic control elements to ensure that
the system is robust you then want it to
be leaky as if it is then there could be
gene expression when we don't want there
to be and the system wouldn't work
and in fact in this paper they did try
various variations and none of the
circuits enabled sustained oscillations
and a major fraction of cells which
demonstrated the importance of
connectivity and strength for feedback
interactions and generating oscillations
now despite this with their robust
system not all of their cells actually
showed sustained oscillations within the
population they could actually see two
groups
those that did oscillate called sustains
and those that continue to increase
certain expression and they deviated
but they're deviated Warrior minority
and by and large the genetic
modifications that they made in the
system works
so did they actually have any influence
over lifespan by having this oscillatory
circuit well among the engineered cells
those aging with sustained oscillations
Ashley had greater lifespan extension
it was 105 increase in lifespan
doubling that of wall type for those of
the sustained oscillation
whilst those with the deviated
oscillations so high of 45 increase
relative to that of the ball type the
unmodified strains
therefore maintaining these oscillations
appears to be important for maximally
extending lifespan
essentially keeping this out in a
prolonged state for indecision
now an interesting question that was
studied in this paper is how does it
compare to known long-lived mutations in
yeast
well if we take a look at this figure
here we can see that this oscillatory
modification matches if not outperforms
some of the currently known long-lived
strains partly because there is less
variance within the oscillatory strain
they actually were able to build such a
robust system here
so what are the key take homes from this
paper well first it goes to show that
it's possible to rationally rewire
cellular Dynamics
as a way to delay cellular aging and
increase longevity
essentially synthetic biology is cool
but this was in use
where there is a dichotomous endgame
in their aging States
and a secretary was understood
is there a way that we can find
Innovative strategies to extend this to
mammalian cells
well hopefully well and I guess we'll
see
but it's important to state that even
most simple design circuits in
biological systems
small perturbations can actually have a
substantial effect
but actually one of the more interesting
findings from the study is essentially
support for programmed aging
which I discussed about in my last video
many Studies have succeeded in
generating specific spatiotemporal
Dynamics and functions with synthetic
Gene circuits
yet it remains a challenge to rationally
engineer our biological traits as
complex as longevity
our work represents a proof of concept
demonstrating the successful application
of synthetic biology to reprogram the
cellular aging process
and may lay the foundation for Designing
synthetic Gene circuits to effectively
promote longevity in more complex
organisms
so essentially I don't think it supports
either way I don't think that's what the
aim of this paper was but what I think
is more important to take from your
study is that while we can intervene and
show genetically that there's ways to
extend longevity
it's better to consider the Dynamics the
layer above a single Gene and to
understand how Gene networks are built
and manipulates those circuits or
redesign those circuits to achieve
desirable outcomes
not simple but pinpointing the tunable
knobs and swappable wires that could be
manipulated to redirect the cell's
natural Dynamics away from aging
towards their healthy States
could be something very well worth
pursuing
so with that I hope you've enjoyed this
brief video into this paper thank you to
my patreon supporters and thank you for
listening